one of the more confusing aspects of the
nun is the fact that VALIC is constantly
manipulating things and it's hard for us
as an audience to get a grip on what's
real and what's not
for the ultimate guide on what exists
and what is just an apparition to stick
around to the end of this video I know
what you're probably thinking oh it's
this guy who jumpscared us let's lock
him up forever
look this video is not about jump scares
it's about things you missed in the Nam
now I do reserve the right to jump scare
at any time during my videos but I don't
usually pull it out for things you
missed all I can say is be on your toes
and let's get into it like I pointed out
when I made this video in the conjuring
- the name of the nun demon Valek is
hidden within many of the scenes like so
and that trend continues here in the nun
for example when we first meet sister
Irene at the religious school she
teaches that when they show the
playground there's a seesaw that some
kids are playing on the bars that make
up the supports of the seesaw spell out
the word Valek then in Burton the
Romanian town near the abbey Frenchie
has sister Irene and father Burke load
their stuff onto a truck the license
plate of the truck
reads va0 one Lak if you remove the
numbers it spells out Valek there's also
a crossword puzzle that father Burke is
seen solving at a couple different times
during the film take a look at some of
the boxes he's written in and you'll see
the words deliveries and creates I bet
you thought I was going to say that it
said VALIC but the fact of the matter is
that the shots weren't on screen long
enough for me to see everything so if
you saw anything pertaining to VALIC or
anything of significance at all leave a
comment telling me what you saw and I'll
pin your comment and you'll be famous
and it'll be a great day for you so
remember when I did that one video where
I explain the deeper meaning behind the
song that comes on the radio in the
commercial for the none well it may have
been all for nothing because the song
that comes on in the actual movie is
different
just remember
the war
you
to me the song is you belong to me by
Joe Stafford like the song that was used
in the commercial it's a cover of an
existing song from that era in this case
the song is used as a direct message
from valack to father Burke a warning
that if he stays in the Abbey he's in
for trouble
Valek is literally telling him you
belong to me now and it's a foreshadow
of the scene where the father is locked
in the coffin were VALIC tortures him it
sure was nice of Alec to leave that
shovel there for sister Irene when she
eventually does find the father while
she's looking for him now phallic lures
her into the chapel where a couple of
interesting things happen first off the
nuns are chanting so she should
immediately know that something is up
because we were just told that they're
taking a vow of silence then sister
Irene sees a red glowing light coming up
from below the alt are a symbol of the
fires of hell manifesting in the abbey
at this point she follows the shadow of
the nun along the wall landing on the
mirror behind her where it's revealed
that VALIC is standing above her however
the figure can only be seen in the
reflection
later on when Frenchie is at the black
bear pub in town he notices a woman
covering up a mirror when he asked about
it the bartender tells him that a young
girl had recently died and it was a
tradition in the town to cover up
mirrors so the deceased do not see their
own reflection remember the photo that
sister Charlotte shows from her time in
Romania in Annabelle creation I had
previously speculated that we would meet
some of the characters from the photo in
the not however system idea sister Ana
and sister Lucia do not appear this is
because sister Charlotte visited the
abbey before the events of the nun took
place you can actually spot the same
photo on the wall when they first come
to the abbey poor sister Charlotte has
no idea that all her friends are dead
another item I speculated on was the
relationship between sister Irene from
the nun and Lorraine Warren from the
conjuring phones I thought that they
might be sisters because they both have
visions of Alec and the actresses who
play them are sisters in real life in
the nun no relationship is confirmed
however I do find it interesting that
the Vatican selected sister Irene to
accompany the father despite the fact
that she's unfamiliar with the area the
father mentions that the Vatican always
has a reason for their selection so I
think it's still possible that two are
related in some way and
has something to do with why she was
sent while we don't get much background
on sister Irene we do get a little more
background on Valek father Burke
researches to find that the abbey was
built by a Duke who wrote books and
opened a gateway to hell this
information may be a nod to the fact
that VALIC is based on the character
from a book called the Lesser Key of
Solomon which I have gone into more
detail on in this video the Gateway was
sealed with the blood of Christ but
reopened later due to a war of some kind
Valek appears as a nun in order to blend
in with the real nuns that reside at the
abbey so my theory about valid possibly
changing forms has gained a little more
weight the other thing that I pointed
out in my previous video about the pages
of the book was this illustration which
appears to be a snake coming out of
someone's face the idea of a snake being
another form of alec is confirmed in the
non father Burke reads a description of
Alec in the book that he finds inside
his coffin which reads VALIC the Defiler
the profane the marquee of snakes there
are plenty of other instances where
snakes are connected to Balak in the non
the thrown thing occupied by the mother
Reverend who might I remind you ends up
being the Baloch has an image embossed
on it of two snakes eating each other
when father Burke chases the apparition
of Daniel into the graveyard during
their night at the Abbey
snakes end up coming out of Daniels
mouth to attack him closer to the end of
the movie the father battles a figure
with a serpent light forked tongue and
in the final battle against phallic
snake wraps itself around the father's
neck and bites him in the eye which ties
right back into the book that the father
found after being trapped in the coffin
which features a single eye on the cover
there are two facets to the ending that
I want to talk about one involving the
manipulation caused by Alec and the
other involving the true identity of
French revealed in the very last scene
first let's talk about Ballack before
heading down into the depths of the
Abbey the characters figure out that
there are no other nuns left phallic has
completely taken over the place it's a
little unclear if the people they met in
the beginning such as the mother
Reverend and sister Juana were alive at
some point or if they were apparitions
of VALIC as well here's my answer
the only real living human nuns at the
Abbey are killed off in the prologue
everyone we see after that is a
distortion caused by VALIC valach poses
is the mother reverend tell father Burke
to stay the night because the nuns are
currently taking about silence and
cannot speak with them this is a trap to
get them locked inside the Abbey I mean
the vow of silence thing is technically
kind of true because they're all dead
when Frenchy discovers the body of
sister Victoria he mentions that he
tried to contact the
but is unable to reach them this is
because sister Victoria was the last nun
we see the body of another one of the
nuns fall out of a tree and land on him
as he leaves the abbey just one of the
many examples of nun corpses throughout
the area there's also one confusing
instance where Irene talks to sister
Juana
but then discovers her corpse moments
later then Ilana seems to be back alive
and a following scene the one she was
really talking to is just one of Alec's
tricks but the body discovered under the
sheet is the real sister Juana who had
died several weeks before there are many
decapitation references that could link
to the death of each of the nuns I
already mentioned the one that fell from
the tree
there's also a statue in the main hall
area where the father is studying whose
head crumbles off when Frenchie saves
father Burke's life he decapitates a
zombie nun with an axe he also noticed
that many of the nuns that haunt the
father and sister Irene are faceless as
is the Jesus figure in the chapel also
in the end credits there's some entity
with a burning head the big reveal of
this movie is actually foreshadowed
right when we first meet Frenchie he's
seen at home feeding his goats goats are
an animal that are often used as a
symbol of demons and the devil and the
french-canadian farmer ends up being
possessed by valack at the end of the
movie in the epilogue we discover his
real name is maurice and he's the man
receiving the exorcism in the clip ed in
Lorain show to their class way back in
the original conjuring a french-canadian
farmer had nothing more than a
third-grade education
yet after he was possessed some of the
best Latin that ever heard
sometimes backwards the dark spirit made
its home in this man like that an
upside-down cross started to appear from
within his body
the big connection to Lorraine's most
feared memory was five years in the
making
did you see this twist coming let me
know in the comments remember to like
this video and be back in next week as
I'll be discussing where the conjuring
franchise will go from here you
definitely won't want to miss out on
that so be sure to subscribe to seize
these worlds for new Horrors every week
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive